what's going on the odyssey 40 over here
at the bleach report and we're gonna
talk about fixing my warriors the first
thing that i would do as general manager
of the warriors rappers such as p-40s
complimentary seats could they show a
lot of support for the team for the
region for the call i think that a home
team advantage and just seeing support
not only that but at the same time the
lover showed back we are fans
my second thing that I would do is uh I
would sighs Steph Curry to a lifetime
deal kim dream on and clay reason why
because they are the core they are the
ones who started it all and they built
it from the ground up like they didn't
there wasn't super stars and they made a
self into superstars I think because of
that they deserve it and the third thing
that I would do is general manager at
the Warriors is I will keep them in the
town because that's where it started
from do I think the move from to San
Francisco was a mistake LT was a mistake
I just know it's gonna be a less
convenient for a lot of people too
because of the traffic in the Bay Area
firstly in the city
I'm a forty and this was fixed to
franchise